New numbers emerging that showed the sad and terrible toll of Australia's wildfire crisis.
A professor at the University of Sydney estimates...
...nearly half a billion animals have been killed by the bushfires...
...that have torched three million hectares of New South Wales alone.
In a statement regarding how he reached the massive figure,...
...Professor Chris Dickman explains...
...it was founded on a report he co-wrote in 2007 for the World Wide Fund for Nature.
It studied the impacts of land clearing on the state's wildlife...
...and obtained estimates on the population density of mammals in the state.
He's now multiplied that by the amount of land hit by the fires.
Temperatures are reaching the high 40s...
...and strong winds could push flames toward more populated areas,...
...widening the path of destruction.